très concentré très tranquille et vous
donner juste le meilleur de vous même
sans vous stressé sur le temps sur les
conditions après le petit préambule
rassurant de la rectrice ses élèves de
3e vont plancher sur l'écrit de français
tu as fait un texte où on devait
répondre à des questions il y avait la
compréhension du texte aussi on aurait
une réécriture ont dicté une rédaction
au programme du brevet figurent aussi
maths histoire-géo physique chimie et
enfin une épreuve dont le principal de
ce collège tient à souligner
l'importance dans les 400 points des
épreuves ponctuelles
il ne faut pas oublier les 100 points
doral qui pour nos élèves représente
quand même un investissement assez
important puisque c'est un oral qui est
travaillée qui répétait pour lequel ils
sont obligés de faire des recherches
j'ai fait un diaporama
on avait on avait quatre domaines à
choisir je choisis parcours à venir et
je racontais mon avenir
cet oral symbolise le souci d' équilibre
recherché avec ce nouveau brevet entre
validation par contrôle continu et
examen final on peut voir des situations
où les élèves arrivés un petit peu
démotivé au brevet parce qu'ils
pensaient qu'il l'avait des gens et donc
là il ya un bon équilibre entre un suivi
régulier par le contrôle continu et puis
la marquise de ce premier examen qui
passe dans leur vie est il des coûts
reprendre l'enjeu parce que c'est pas
gagné avant de démarrer en tout cas le
mode d'évaluation seul objet d'un
véritable débat
il ya beaucoup d'élèves de très bons
élèves qui perdent leurs moyens dû au
stress et le fait qu'on ait la
possibilité d'avoir un peu près la
moitié des points durant le contrôle
continu
ça permet quand même de rassurer les
personnes
le contrôle continu n'empêche pas
l'évaluation éventuellement chiffrés et
d'ailleurs les élèves je crois si
retrouve peut-être mieux que les adultes
mais c'est une très bonne chose d'y
réfléchir
l'esprit du brevet lui reste inchangé il
s'agit toujours de valider l'ensemble
des compétences acquises durant la
scolarité obligatoire